okay I'm
back got some
sleep it's 11:29 a.m. Central
Time about 6 and 1 half hours left of
the
tournament I streamed somewhere between
I think it was 7 and 1 half to 8
hours last night into early this morning
so I'm refreshed I just had an apple got
some water got some green tea
I guess if you're watching on YouTube in
the future this will be part two this
will be the the finale to the winter
marathon when I finished the stream last
night I was in the top 20 I've dropped
to I guess I'm in the top 420 still so I
don't know what my goal is like to
finish as high as possible leader has
points but maybe it's possible to finish
with over 500
so I think like top top 50 is a a doable
goal a lot of players have been
playing much longer than me um I think
I'll just hop into it 31 months wow so
much chess thank you Ziggy P welcome
back here we
go um I'm not going to berserk I want to
build a streak and then depending on my
opponents I might
berserk I'm going to play
an
Italian play D3 keep it solid I don't
think I played this exact opening last
night uh B4 is already a big
threat I've saved the bishop so Knight
can't
take I do feel very refreshed compared
to what I felt like towards the end of
my
stream very early this
morning okay opponent wants to hurt me
now I'm threading B4 to trap the
bishop so black has to do something
maybe
takes okay B4 wins the bishop there is
takes and Knight
G4 so I guess P gets a rook and pawn for
night and
Bishop than you due to symmetry good
luck and happy almost New
Year yeah happy December
29th right
29th yeah
29th I think yesterday I got the date
wrong
um okay so up a piece
uh we'll do the typical Italian things
Bishop E3 Knight
G3 um taking probably
this
I might have some idea of like taking on
C6 eventually with Knight
[Music]
E7 yeah I think it's going to work cuz
I'm hitting this it's basically a skewer
and I'm threatening
this and if okay Queen B5 is probably
the most likely move and then I
take a nice little Queen sack to start
the new
day Eric you've inspired me to be 1950
in Puzzles and 1
,250 in Rapid I can't stop with the
gambits
[Music]
ooh uh I guess you're welcome also black
is kind of surviving
[Music]
here I mean I can take on
D6 still up a
piece I didn't quite get the tactics
that I was thinking I would
get up a lot of time here
too thank you zun keep it
up yeah it's normal for your puzzle
rating to be much higher
than uh your other online
ratings Rook B5 Queen
C6 um I can take this Rook C1 Knight
E1 resubbing for good luck energy thank
you guess Rook
B1 cuz Queen takes I take everything's
covered it's like a right
triangle A2 + B2 =
c^2 oh yes my
[Music]
theorem thank you Malcolm
Reynolds I'm threatening this uh no I'm
not
okay up a knight
[Music]
still I'm threatening this and then
this he's back oh yes my sleep go for
6.5
hours
okay
pretty clean first game there I'll
berser this
game hey it's Sharma what's up Sharma I
am back welcome back to you as well
you've inspired me to become puzzles and
Rapid I can top with the
plits to become puzzles in
Rapid when you can't solve the puzzle
become the
puzzle
okay so we have a London this is a nice
anti- London setup provoke B3 develop
the bishop play probably E6 next move
opponent begging for a
draw try and uh get rid of this bishop
there's this
pin life is pretty
good KN G5 might be coming okay now I'm
going to win this
Pawn there's some cool mating ideas that
maybe will pop
up okay I wanted to play this move say
oh no my knight and then oh no my rook
and then
Checkmate but
uh okay game ended kind of
abruptly so playing a new
opponent um no berserking and keep it
chill thank you electric muffin and
Goulet fam appreciate the
subs yeah E3 blocks the bishop
early now the the goal is to Castle
Queen E7 develop the bishop and then
eventually Knight to
E4
hey it's Nate Brady do you have any
chess or content resolutions for the new
year that's a great
[Music]
question um I want to I want to do at
least 50 episodes of the
speedrun uh I'm 16 episodes
[Music]
in
so maybe first maybe the first goal is
to get to like 20 and eventually 50
maybe someday
100 it would be cool to do like a
different themed speedrun
to like a gambits and tricky opening
[Music]
speedr opponent really wants a
draw was all these opponents offering
draws and black is a little bit for
Choice here because of this Pawn fixed
on
D5
I think the king just wants to come
[Music]
in Bishop restricts the Knight so any
Knight check I just take
it keep attacking the
pawn I do want to play some more chest
tournaments
too um but I don't know what my term in
schedule will be
like it' be cool to like play some
tournaments and have the games live
streamed like with a live
cam like an the cramling or botes style
takes more work to set
up sometimes it helps if the tournament
organizer can set things up or set those
those sort of things
up thank you for the love the tune
thank you saan the first time
[Music]
Prime
matriarchal
um asking if is chess available on
Playstation I don't know I I don't think
I've ever owned a
PlayStation let's attack the
Knight
actually there
there this
move after the
[Music]
pawn good luck good health and good
games thank you
Oly okay so Knight's restricted by the
bishop G6 is coming or I guess King B2
was also coming or
queening
okay so
369 220 tournament
points I'm trying to recover my rating
too I think I started the tournament
like in the high
2500s Marathon tournaments usually do
cause the rating to have a down
[Music]
swing okay let's play we'll play a
fornight scotch how
about Bishop
D3 and Bishop
D2 it's a sideline it's the line I
played in Qatar the final
round
D4 is maybe a
move
D4 is a little bit
[Music]
overextending think now the goal is to
build up on the king
side to prevent C4
there yeah basically F4 F5 Rook e
one I might play H3
first cuz F4 there's
E3 now yeah now I have more access to
attack the C5 Pawn which is
[Music]
backwards think King
H2 looks a little a little bit
scary it should be
manageable F4 is defended C5 is attack
twice that chai Town dude welcome back
motivation I appreciate the
motivation we also appreciate a queen
trade or another Free Pawn
take take
take yeah this should
work if takes let check here and then
here and then win The
Rook Rook f8 I mate
okay staying clean that's five in a
row I guess uh the first game of this
five in a row streak was played at the
very end of the stream this
morning but uh okay we keep it going
playing
Matt let's play an attempted Stafford
Knight E5 Knight
C6 yeah this is a fall line for
white this is probably going to take
some
work play H5 or
H4 Queen
[Music]
here remember Fabiano playing this move
like the one game he played the Stafford
he played some interesting like A6
B5 take
so many opponents offering draws
today uh no
draw I'm down the pawn maybe I probably
should have taken the draw
but um it's a better story regardless if
I just play
on even if it might be
[Music]
painful
I just got
trapped oh it's kind of painful
oops
yeah this is going to probably going to
be my first loss
of the second
stream unless I can work some
[Music]
miracle
so I'm down a bishop and two or down a
exchange and two
pawns throw the
check here would be
mate
yeah there's not much hope
here
I'm trying to be tricky it's not really
working
though um yeah I resign
okay ah such as Life One played well
maybe should have taken the
draw they tried to show some mercy oh no
my Stafford oh no my Stafford
let's keep it
going try not to tilt I'll try not to
fall below
2500 thank you jolon thank you
Dave okay I'll go for the early H Pawn
thrust F3 preventing Knight
G4 I'm not sure if I want to go for G4
F4 going forward
here
ooh was
unexpected C3 is
coming
oh top 30 has 406 points yeah it's going
to take a while to get back
there I'd be very H very happy with top
50 but it takes a lot of
work it requires consistent winning
too watching from Malaysia 1:48
[Music]
a.m. yeah when I was streaming earlier
it was like a normal time in
Malaysia it was like 1:48
[Music]
p.m. okay what to do let's we'll just be
solid up a
[Music]
PA threatening this
think the Knight LA to come to
C4 now it wants to come to
E5 preventing Queen
H3 yeah this is a weak point so
something like Rook
B6 might also be threatening
[Music]
this
I'll probably win the
pawn was not easy to
[Music]
defend going after this
Pawn
queen
d8 queen
C5 attacking
D4 so White's up three pawns up a lot of
time
[Music]
too
opponent may be going for Queen
B1 oh there's my
G4 okay this should be mating now like
check and then check and then
meet okay
352 okay let's
berserk giving time
odds play a bit quickly a bit more
quickly
here a bit
quicker combining quicker and
quickly hi to philas how's it
going
I'm trying to orchestrate some type of
attack maybe G5
G4 get rid of this
bishop Knight E5 might be
[Music]
coming
maybe I should have played Bishop F4
[Music]
first okay now I have takes Knight D2
oh but I H
D5 I'm down upon pawn and down a
minute
over defending
[Music]
G7 oh I'm struggling
here this is going to be hard to crack
too if I
take
yeah I have like very few
[Music]
plans
that's not
good okay
wow
uh I mean white could have sack the
queen appropriately with Queen jigs
B8 but uh okay I was in big big trouble
there like really big
trouble
I think I had a good position from the
middle game but completely gave
everything
away playing ganto bear who I think was
watching
yesterday remember the name from twitch
chats okay
let's do I want to do
C6
yeah we'll trade a
bunch so this could be a pawn tree like
win C4 lose
B7 maybe just Queen
D7 try and keep it
solid A5 is
[Music]
coming
I want to rearrange the pieces Knight's
not happy here
anymore it was pressuring the pawns but
now the pawns are pressuring the
Knight if I take on
D5 looks
interesting I win
A5 Rook A1 oh no there's not Rook
A1 Bishop is strong I defend
A5 so I'll play
this KN C5
[Music]
too so attacking
defending ensuring that once this Rook
moves B7 will still be
defended B6 coming
next ooh
tactics
I think this is more
[Music]
practical
this
idea Knight
D6 night is usually the best block haer
hey it's vampire chicken appreciate the
raid hope you had a good
one I assume streaming risk maybe
streaming the
marathon oh yeah we have the Jonathan
command
too if you're just joining I'm playing
chess I'm playing a 24-hour
tournament also I'm down on time I got
to
focus start with this and Rook
C7 that down on time up a
pawn play this
move B7
coming
yeah white can win back the
pawn I don't think white can win this
Pawn
though
three on
three is there a draw offer
there
no a what to
do
H I think there was a draw offer
probably should have taken
it uh
okay sometimes those
situations focusing on moves rather than
looking for the
offers oh I should um yeah my watch has
been charging but oh let's play the
ortho shop in honor of Jonathan take
Queen B3 orthosnap Gambit
time
okay how do I play this opening
again also connecting my heart
rates
I if the pawn pushes or moves
there I just sack the
Knight I'll sack the Knight having some
fun okay there is a heart
rate I was probably over 100 that last
game
so I'm down a knight but the king's on
E7 so for spawn
[Music]
Cloud think I'll take this
way Knight C5 may be
coming KN C5 Bop a
three takes there Bishop
A3 this is basically what I
want Bishop D5 is a double
attack if Knight moves I have Bishop G5
when the
queen even if the knight's offended like
Bishop F5 I can take and Bishop
G5
[Music]
oo
trying to calculate Bishop A3
here start by doing
this
this the calculation is King D7 E6 King
here Bishop
C6
oh actually um Bishop E6 might be more
efficient that's made in three here here
and then Queen E6
checkmat oh it's not me though
oops what did I
do it's not made
oh cuz I no longer control
[Music]
C7 uh let's take Queen
D5 that was a brain
slip wind D5 is probably not a great
move
Tak and play
F3 okay I'm still down a piece down to
Bishop for three
[Music]
pawns I still like my
chances
Knight's coming to
C4 play
this
have some nice looking Center
control pawns go
marching
okay okay
feel a little bit bad
there some things were missed earlier
I'm
sure keeping the 2500
rating playing JP
champ trying to
redeem the
Stafford
okay so this
[Music]
line Queen
D4 Rook F1 is the best
move
so I have to trade
Queens down two pawns
here
I should probably stop playing the
Stafford H has been prepared this
[Music]
game okay but I'm winning back
upon I wi another
Pawn
m
in some
[Music]
trouble
she really not sure what to do
here
so why has the two
passers it's hard to get them rolling
like so
quickly
that's not
good
I'm down three
pawns soon to
[Music]
be4
holding on to my last
one my final
baby
ah okay I was trying to
run uh
uh what to
do I'm try and be more
solid we will have a
PS um what do we call this the check
purs going for a quick kingside
attack
yeah there's no Knight
H5 a knight D5 I'm probably ready to
take
and if anything blocks I can take on uh
D6 tournament
tournament it's a long tournament there
going to be lots of ups and
downs got to stay mentally
tough
also can I just sack a a
thing calculation is takes takes takes
and then Queen
F4 which um yeah looks pretty
winning welcome back to
Donuts
scared me for a
moment but things are still
controlled
okay I'll try and get everyone
involved
don't really want to trade Queens but I
think I have
[Music]
to
okay 340 takes
work I'm try and build a streak playing
JP champ who is very prepared for the
Stafford so this is my chance for
Revenge switch up the opening play
Sicilian maybe some uh acceler
dragon
F3 okay go for
D5
a lot of attacking
potential Queen A5 in the
air you ever play kocon pretty
rarely it's not an opening that um I
really ever got into from the black
[Music]
side partly because there's so many
things white can do against
it and at a high level it requires is a
lot of um lot of
[Music]
preparation yeah light's Under Pressure
here but how to crack the position
Bishop
F5 looks
decent G4 might be
coming
it feels very close to being able to
like sack on
[Music]
B2 like maybe I play this
first and if B3 and then I can take on
B3 takes
takes but then there's Knight
A2 not super
clear
White's burning a lot of time
here
wow could take on F3
now attacking the rook and the pawn
oh that move I
[Music]
missed guess
I guess I just have to lose a
piece N4 take take doesn't work Bishop
[Music]
C2 this is question Bishop
C2 might as
well
threading Knight
D2 down a piece for a couple
Pawns
no why I was I was just too
slow also I had Maiden one ah
I think I just like I got way too
relaxed there with no
time oh no my
time okay playing ganto bear who beat me
the previous game playing against a
caroon I'll play
um I'll play Knight
C3 play this
line try and move a bit more
quickly
we're following my game from uh
Qatar
where yeah I got the Knight to
D6 I think Knight
C4 I think we're still following the
game like Queen C7 Castle Queen side
rook d8 and then
[Music]
G4 now I have this
move it's getting
spicy maybe
G4 and G4 G5 looks nice
does it lead to anything Knight
D6 take the Rook
first
I really just have to stay awake
here I think um I have to do
this there
B4 like B4 B5
I had F4
[Music]
too F4 can come
next up a full Rook
here
um okay
there's the
checkmates
okay it's been a while since I've had a
streak I think I've only had one streak
this stream the very beginning playing
soy la
yet okay I'll take some this of this
game
berserk we have
a Grand Pre
attack
I thought I would easily win back the
pawn
but it's going to take some
work thring
[Music]
B4
allowing this and then I'll take and
then take and then King
F7
this is looking pretty good
[Music]
now maybe go for
G5
plans a double on the C
[Music]
file
oops I love n6 for a moment
there okay let's move quickly
enough
okay that's two in a row try make a
three
preventing
ig5
okay so up a
[Music]
pawn
a very solid game so
far wi another
Pawn I'm up three
pawns some pressure
though
F3 I think I
take and then
take still have three
pawns okay
that's three in a row got my berserking
point the five berserking tournament
points um I'll keep it
going I'm try and find some Rhythm
here
a few
choices this is a typical tactic uh
tactical
Motif okay 13 move win
almost top
300 feeling
good
yeah this is some like theoretical
London line that um can be dangerous for
both
sides blocks under a lot of pressure
now
so I have the bishop
pair attacking
[Music]
B7 Bishop d8 maybe like take on F7 or
still take
here Rook was
overworked yeah okay some quick
wins
281 that's uh what five in a row four
berserking games in a
row oh playing JP champ my arch
nemesis okay JP champ has beat me twice
so far this
tournament uh this
line play this
first
a solid line for
white
okay got the bishop
pair King should probably go to
f8 yeah the previous game was the one I
I flagged with uh Missing Maiden one
it's not my proudest
[Music]
game maybe
A5 thank you Justin conclusive happy New
Year in advance Eric appreciate
it
okay I'll get some funny Bond structure
I
guess
if white wants to
take
now the bishop does a nice job
restricting the
Knight Rook
F3
Rook attacking
F3 if takes takes takes I take on
G4
okay I'm not going to mess this one
up
hopefully
um let's move up with the
things hooray for
friendship oh yeah ask my
friendship
okay the win streak continues let's go
275 257 tournament
points hey it's Kung Vu Chas hope you're
doing well it's been a while since I
played Kung Fu
chess uh I'll play D4 here sometimes I
play
H4
Play Bishop
B5 it's a weird line engine probably
slightly prefers black
but
um yeah already looks like I'm getting
compensation
though I
check
it's almost like forc mate Queen E3 this
is only
move
okay uh yeah if this it's also
mate okay 13 move win smother mate think
I get a Rosen trophy for
that play E4
again South African
rhino
we'll play a more more traditional Grand
Prix Bishop
E5
ah yes nothing beats the rose and
Marathon stream fancy a challenge for
the rest of this
tournament what kind of
challenge I was given a few challenges
in the the previous stream
which I had difficulty uh succeeding
in also Queen
D7 Queen D7 C no
C3
there it's too
confusing I don't think it
works just play Queen
D2
G4
yeah most of blocks things are on this
side looking to double
up
ooh I have to be careful
here
uh that's not
[Music]
good maybe some
chances
black has Rook two Rooks and a bishop
for a
[Music]
queen
might be able to draw
this
okay
wow oh that was close that was really
close the streak continues
also thank you manging gifting to some
name I really can't
pronounce okay
berserk
yeah already not looking good for white
I mean Knight E2 I'm taking
knight4
meanwhile
um Queen G2 Rook G1 I'll take
it tactical Rampage here
okay that's a feel good
game a bit smoother than the previous
game so
242 playing s
Sasha thank you
fromaz uh Queen C2 supposed to play this
I
think what mlay sometimes
plays Pawn's not actually hanging cuz
Queen would be
overworked thank you Erica
Amy
O Okay so White's going for
it it looks
scary I mean here I have this
move think everything is
covered
yeah Knight Knight E7 will defend the
king the pawn offer the queen trade all
the pawns are defended D covered Queen
trade is
forced I'll be up a piece for two
pawns threatening this
[Music]
move
if I take is this
first
I got to move quicker
here
for
clutch
Knights
okay I've lost counted how many games
I've won in a row but still feeling
good trying to stay controlled thank you
Gary loves
pizza gifting to
652 oops okay opponent doesn't take my
[Music]
Pawn play a little bit too quickly
there
so I have the bishop
hair trying and be
solid Queen here attacks both pawns but
then I have this Rook E1
move probably just trade
Rooks
actually I take with Pawn
actually I take with Bishop
probably
Saka
Pon two on
[Music]
one
m
and Bishop C8 is coming or Bishop
B8 you got this I'm
trying this still takes a lot of
work
thank you righteous
[Music]
Rangel up on time which is
nice yeah black can't tra the bishop
because I have the
[Music]
wall
but how do I
escape
okay I I was to try and go for a mating
attack with the two Bishops a nice
finish
okay no berserking this
game
D3 d E3 play Knight
F6 have one of
these
I probably should take
that's kind of
risky let's go for it
up a piece but uh yeah the G file is
scary and the plan is to win
at5
or just to neutralize the G
file F3 comes to
mind hey it's Anna cramling thank you
Anna cramling I think that was actually
Pia cramling right doing commentary for
Anna's games although maybe Anna makes a
appearance at the
end
raid from Anna she got a big W
congratulations to
[Music]
Anna yeah if you're just joining I'm
playing the the leeches winter
marathon it's uh Happy 50 months a
24-hour long
tourament I streamed the first almost
eight hours
of and this is going to be the final now
now less than 5 hours a lot of Chess in
24 hours
okay I just want to simplify UPA
Bishop no need to do anything too
crazy thank you shailo
stand I could take here
actually Queen takes Pawn I uh I win the
queen I'm friending the bishop and the
queen this is um yeah King D1 Queen B1
is checkmate
okay so I have a nice winning
streak
um I've
won 119 to 130 so 12 games in a
row try and keep it going playing Matt
who beat me
earlier I'll play a Lon against Matt try
and be
solid opponent wants to
draw no
thanks
I've been offered a lot of premature
draws this
tournament more so earlier
though this
move okay it's a confusing sentence
I think I'll just
Castle I could also take take take maybe
taking is
better there's an idea here to just
trade everything and then
95 eventually
F3
yeah The Bishop's finding a diagonal
unfortunately my knight should return E5
eventually
I could play Knight
D2 and rookie
[Music]
one yeah with the Knight versus Bishop
inbalance it could be a three years old
game this move now idea is to play C5
and then get the three on two
majority the bishop looks pretty but
it's not really doing that
much kind of like a Christmas
ornament yeah C5 is
coming
think you twice twice hopped the first
time
sub these pawns are past pawns but
they're hard to
mobilize um throw in the check maybe
Rook
[Music]
F7
calculation is this and then
this I'm not allowing Rook T8 okay now I
have
this still allowing Rook
T8 yeah i' I went very wrong
[Music]
here still maybe okay
A4
confusing
[Music]
position
can't take
that
appreciate the
raid you're just joining a little bit
preoccupied
okay got the win thank you elanna 86
really appreciate
it let me give some shout outs shout out
to Anna cring who rated shout out to
elenna again if you're just joining this
will be a long stream we have 4 hours
and 46 minutes to go
all right let's play
Sicilian oh this is what uh Magnus
played against me a few weeks ago in
title
Tuesday I think I'll play D4
here double edge
move
so I'm up a
PA C3 I could play
D3 see how white tries to win it
back that's a decent
[Music]
move
very weird
position but we have something
fresh kind of forgot about
that Queen B7 is now a
threat um
Queen
C7 defending
attacking F4 maybe
G5 I could take the
[Music]
pawn
I guess I'll go for the queen trade
E5 maybe
E6 bit more
solid combines better with the bishop
too oh that's a
[Music]
move Rook be
eight taking a play
this oh it still wins the P white
though in some trouble
here I mean white doesn't have the best
structure
I have one Pawn Island white has three
Pawn
[Music]
Islands C4 is
coming actually with C4 I think I can
play this and then take the Rook would
be
overworked so okay I win the pawn
back and this is now a pass
Pawn
I
take tricky tricky take
[Music]
take I can't really defend the
pawn
H oh I can no I
can't let's go for
this F5
H6 Bishop f8 Rook
G8
takes I take with
check I don't know if I win the pawn my
King's on a better Square
[Music]
too yeah I win this Pawn now I can maybe
go for a fork or
something playing for a win
here finding a
fork oops I pler the Knight
okay it's a
draw
H I don't think I missed any Forks
though why I play KN
F4 okay there goes my win streak I still
have an unbeat streak
of uh 13
games or 14 games I I can't do
math oh no my Knights I was fortunate
there I was probably have the worst
position I'll play
G3 so this started as a closed Sicilian
trying to transpose into open
Sicilian
playing some combination of like a
dragon
[Music]
chingan
um play A4 typical
move have to be careful here
there is the eventual plan of plan of B3
and Bishop
[Music]
B2 although I'm under a lot of
pressure
I might just be losing a
pawn
B3 doesn't
work I'm losing a pawn light B2 is
[Music]
playable maybe I can throw in
A5
A5 takes Bishop
D4 along Bishop B5 in some lines
so okay down the pawn threatening D6
not the end of the
world maybe threatening this now there
would be Rook
[Music]
C4 if I take I lose
C2
[Music]
okay keep all the
attention unleashing the
bishop attacking the pawn and the Knight
Knight C6 is
expected let's move
to giving up
F2 the hope is to take and uh take on
B7 G3 is hanging I can't
really deal
with
this Pawn is now potentially
strong it's not so much about the
quantity of Pawns it's about the quality
of Pawns this a pawn is a quality
Pawn oops I'm losing another
Pawn
Rook A2 I have Rook
D2
looks like I'm winning this Pawn even if
Rook A2 I take Knight Discovery I move
the
Rook Knight B4 is maybe the trickiest
because then if I block there's a
fork oh that wins a pawn
actually opponent doesn't find it
tricky super
tricky
[Music]
B3
okay
okay opponent just fell victim to the
time
trouble God I played most of the game
there but
got the job done trying to close in on
top
200 trying to play something
solid yeah this is some obscure opening
preparation Queen G3 pretty strong
move like this and then
this
I used to play this more for black the
so-called Schmid
defense pretty sure this is a way to go
and then like Queen
C3
here there a few
options
it just
takes okay some discoveries
now attacking the bishop and queen
develop with
Tempo very pleasant game so
far black is trying to
consolidate
yeah materials
[Music]
equal um let's not hang a
knight and now it's turning into a
positional
game
let's not blunder let's
take offer some
trades yeah maybe there was some Mis
opportunities earlier
there still some pressure attacking two
undefended
Pawns
defending still
attacking also attacking
this I don't think black can save
everything I might as well
take can
check
slowly but
surely
okay
yeah trying to be solid trying to stay
clean was a pretty clean
game a bit of opening preparation
there
berserk staffer Gambit not
quite
I can try and play more aggressive so I
haven't committed to
castling maybe some Rook G8 and
H5 it's hard for white to do much in the
center
um start with
this I might be trapping the bishop like
Knight D2
G3 Knight would
hang I win The
Rook
nice pressure
here now the pieces are all ready to
attack okay
um top
200 back on the berserking street
almost 300 tournament
points playing Lightning McQueen
berserk toble
berserk
just trying to be very solid
here
Rook D7
coming okay we can
trade nice example of like winning a
pawn in the opening and then just
trading
everything and then hopefully converting
the end game
[Music]
Eon is pinned
okay 304 tournament points oh playing
this opponent
again trying to remember the
opening I think I played E4 against this
opponent
before now we have something a bit
different
this is a nice uh London opening
drop it's already like very winning for
white um I can take and
then there's a few winning options
[Music]
here Knight takes F7 is
coming
black is
[Music]
fighting so I'm up a full Rook for the
time being probably end up losing the
Knight maybe I can Rescue
It
a7's
hanging I think I'll start with
F3
okay so making up some rating points I
don't get too many points for a win
[Music]
though so berserk B3 three we'll play
one of
these
okay no
mercy
um this almost traps a
queen
okay no
mercy
okay I think there's a lot of players
that have been playing for way way
longer than me or
maybe dealing with some sleep
[Music]
deprivation like towards the end of a
tournament like this we'll see a lot
more blunders
I'm going to play a tarash haven't
played a tarash in a
[Music]
while
like one goal in position like this is
to try and get the bishop
pair especially a pretty open
position
oo
let's
take yeah this will be an endgame grind
coming
up
I don't think black can take the H
Pawn takes King here and Rook moves and
then
F3 maybe it's
possible actually maybe King E2
F3 now I want to play this and then
invade
some idea of G5 and then Rook
D7 this Knight D5 is maybe
coming let's start with
this
King d8 Bishop here B
E5 I think I have to
take that's kind of drawsh
[Music]
now but I have the time
Advantage try and play for something
here
these positions can sometimes have a
draw tendency but sometimes they can get
really sharp too so I'll be fighting for
light squares black will be controlling
dark
squares G6
now let's do this
first I was tempting to take
um do this and
this okay up a
pawn
up two
PS oops meant to take the
thing
okay keep it going
153 this is the highest rated I've been
in a long
time
in 19 t7 I wonder if that was some sort
of like Mouse
slip this is really really nice
now
Simple Plan Queen H5 and
Checkmate
okay top
150 making
progress I'm feeling good let's
berserk play a
Sicilian
I have to take with
that so D5 E5 is a
dream Black's trying or White's trying
to destroy my dream rout D1 gets m in a
[Music]
few so I have a nice big
Center no draw just
yet
okay this might be heading towards a
draw
I have one idea in the position I'm
trying to
calculate let's go for
right oh that was a bad
move
so much
regret
a okay I over
pushed although I think I I made the
right decision I just made a a very bad
move where was
it I guess I should have started with
this and then just
D3 here it might not already actually
here I can still play E3 check at taking
was was very
bad
okay
so the regret was not declining the draw
the regret
was not playing the right move in the
the critical
moment so the streak has come to an
end but hopefully a new streak will be
born let's play a a wing
Gambit been playing a lot of different
things against French this
tournament
I think I've seen Queen A5
before so there some Queen E4 check
wow Queen
C1
one of the ideas is
to get a knight to
D6 other ideas is to build the center
Bishop D3
C3 maybe
G4
okay I want to get to the
square
it's getting
tactical but the good kind of tactical
oh no my
Rook
try playing king of one
there my king wants to get to
[Music]
B7 no Pawn for
you
okay black could have delivered a pin in
the final
position
okay
144 playing in due time thank you Mr
fish at the first time
Prime
H4 ooh have C4 here
I can't play
B3 this
move I just lost a
pawn uh what to do
F3
let's carry on with
life King
[Music]
B1 I mean the extra Pawn that black is
up basically on the king side it's a
crippled majority the double
pawns I'm still
[Music]
playable
King
B2 so I did UND double blackx pawns but
this is kind of backwards
[Music]
now go for
queen2
maybe another
four yeah momentum is
Shifting still
tricky
there's Queen
A6 and the calculation is takes Queen A6
King
B8 okay this should be
similar the plan's Knight
C5 so I'm basically threatening the rook
and
checkmates even though my knight and
Rook are not sufficiently
defended let have this move
now and there's two threats which I
don't think black can
stop oh didn't see that move
[Music]
though am I
losing play this I might be
losing and there's also King
B3 try
this queen D2 King
here
okay no I'm getting
mated wow I put my king on the wrong
Square I probably have to play King
A1 or King to the background
rank yeah King C1 King A1 or King
B1 and then White's Ming by force ah
what to
do that's slightly
sad but it's a wakeup
call playing am
bronen
okay we're going to have
a pseudo Catalan play
this
E4 is probably
coming put the bishop on
[Music]
C7 oops hung a
pawn
[Music]
94 that's a free
Knights it took me a moment to spot that
let play this unpinning the
nights
for
okay oh was not easy
there oh
man another wakeup
call yeah top 100 is going to be hard to
get
to try and get a berserking streak
play
[Music]
H4
that was a very nice
gift still not over though
[Music]
for
okay that was a weird game thank you
Christian OSP with the first time
Prime playing
Maxim pass Gambit
time G3
not something you see every
day okay I'm try and be
aggressive F3 I can take
I want to play
G5
yeah White's probably okay
here probably have to trade
[Music]
Queens
looks like I should be winning the
[Music]
pawn expecting this and then
this
thank you motor
bris appreciate the
sub
Rook a one Bishop C6 not
happening yeah White's a bit stuck on
the king
side
okay keep it
going I may have may have been in a
little bit of trouble there end game was
slightly worse but somehow it turned
[Music]
around okay
um ah I remember this
opponent staffer Gambit
time thank you ready player
one
and this looks very
[Music]
strong attacking these things if takes H
file
opens this line I can
take
okay Stafford Gambit
success keep it
going we're trying to close in on the
top
100 playing a two nights
attack
hey it's schwarma hey finally stord
Gambit win the king's Gambit now oh yeah
I forgot about the king's
Gambit had that crazy uh stalemate
game it was like a long time
[Music]
ago I didn't have a chance to play Kings
gav in this
game
trying to win the
eong if I
take and
then okay let's take
here whoa it streams on Twitch gifting
10 appreciate
that really appreciate the
energy I'm running low on D so
helps to have various forms of
energy I'm up a pawn
here
oops losing
A3
hello Eric cheers to 19
months oh losing another
Pawn okay I got to
focus
okay let's go barely just
barely thank you K pen thank you marmal
charade okay we'll play tyano if how
abouts
Queen
F3 F4 is the main line
here Bishop
F4 think this is also
[Music]
playable it does look
scary
yeah this is some like weird
Theory Knight
H4 I have to take and King
[Music]
E7
oh that's not
good try this
no oh that's really not
good everything's
attacked okay opening gone
wrong
I mean what can I try
this I have a rook for Knight and Five
Pawns but why just want back The Rook so
I'm just down Five Pawns
here uh let's went the
upon
okay I resign uh real quick let me take
an opening lesson I know this is
some some deep
Theory engine says it's playable for
Black Knight H5 is the only move
yeah somewhere like deep in my chest
space files I have this line it's been a
while
okay keep it
going have a
Catalan I think I played only against
Only One Catalan
earlier ran into Knight
[Music]
D2
so there's a typical idea yeah B5
here I'll win back the
pawn so making a battery opponent may be
oblivious to
that
I still have to play
solidly one idea might be Bishop C6 and
B4 prevent Knight
[Music]
A4 start by
taking
if I
take yeah just trying to keep control
here
hey Z Nation hey you passed your exam to
become a licensed financial adviser
congratulations that's awesome to
hear let's play this
move okay so now Queen and Knight are
attacked
and the pawns
attacked yeah it's good to have multiple
uh potential paths in life and then
choose the most practical
one okay up a ooh
oh no White's Queen someone call an
ambulance but yeah not for me
okay
okay let's keep it going
berser D5
yeah try and hold on to the
pawn four Defenders four
attackers big focal
point
okay this drops a
bishop
still trying to be
solid C5 probably coming queen defends
B2 oops Queen no longer defends B2 but
that's okay now it
does
okay trying to raise the
raining
keep it going thank you looking for Easy
Street
up a couple pawns
here using the open
files
I'm anticipating Rook Rook E8 okay never
mind
rookie I can take on G2
yeah oh no my
queen
okay that was
pleasant on the berserking
streak oh King's Gambit time here we
go Kings Gambit
declined interesting
variation getting a good
position nice
Center opposite side castling
this pawns
attacked
D5
have to watch my
[Music]
time defending the
pawn
so Rook G1 and then Pawn storming is one
idea
so these things are
attacked
thank you hi Eric thank you person hello
I don't want to butcher your
name uh can I take
this
Thor I just call you
Thor happy 20
months
okay I really gota move quicker
here we trade
Queens should be routine
now I can just like play on the light
squares
oops my attempt on playing on the dark
okay
oh
114 keep it
[Music]
going opponent not berserking
back so I have my work cut
out have a fun London
line
h
what I do
here
in some
[Music]
trouble some com
play this should be a draw
now
okay CH is a
draw thank you shamat I was definitely
in trouble with that game so fortunate
to
survive
oh my queen oh no someone call an
ambulance
someone
[Music]
anyone yeah opponents opponent sees
through my trickery
unfortunately now am I losing material I
might be have this
[Music]
move oh no my queen
again oh yes my double check doesn't do
much I'm going to be down a
peas maybe I can go for a dirty
flag um um think I have to
take no
draw
okay now the clean this
game try to produce some funniness that
game
11 playing
chocolate thank you spooney ice
cream converting Prime to tier
one okay we have one of
these solid position for both
sides plan is to play Queen
A2 very close to having Bishop
[Music]
F7 take a moment
here might as
[Music]
well cuz I'll have Knight E6
guaranteed I think black has to play
this
hm
another
five looks good down a piece
but takes and then
takes takes probably
F4 but then Queen C5
check
Queen is still useful from
A2
okay so I'm down to exchange for four
Pawn or three
pawns yeah three
Pawns
Bishop should go to
D4 almost trapping The Rook
actually I can get the king to
D1 which should be doable like put the
bishop on
D4
black will probably take and then
take but this should be a i it's still
much
better I have four Pawn Islands black
has two Pawn
islands all the pawns are
isolated
yeah The Rook likes to go behind the
pass
Pawn
just for good
measure um
also for good
measure it's still winning like I could
have run the king
but black was threatening
Perpetual
okay rating is still
increasing 366
the you farm fresh
fine the first time
Prime
h
uh
oh that's not
good uh maybe it's
playable B4 I can
take not the move I really want to
play
h
little bit slow I took the Rook ends in
the
draw chess as a
draw
okay what to expect
here the barman
[Music]
variation it's already looking pretty
good trade Queens l in a
pawn
[Music]
go for
E5
take under some pressure
though this
move
that
ah oh a little bit too slow there what
to
do it's okay
though life goes
[Music]
on
109 playing Dark
Moon
missed opportunity for the moon
flare okay playing uh a wing gabit
against the
French I think it's already nice for
white oops okay now it's nice for
black I should have just taken
there
so I'm down
[Music]
upon try and stir up
something if I
take block wants to
Checkmate I just want to be solid
I'm down two pawns cuz I gam the pawn
and I blunder the pawn
oops okay this will take some work
[Music]
then like maybe I can win back a
pawn D5 is a long-term
Target threatening this
[Music]
move this Pawn has been hanging for a
little
bit now I can't take it
though we'll put on the pressure against
D5 three attackers one
Defender problem is if I take it then we
simplify a
lot I think I'll play
this Rook side down to the A7
[Music]
Pawn okay now if I
take at least I'll have some
activity
okay I'm down two pawns but this rook's
very
passive I guess it is supporting the
pass
[Music]
Pawn the plan is if F5 I play Rook
E5 and now I just want a
checkmat going for a mating attack in
the end
[Music]
game I think it's likely black will have
to play Rook h8 at some
point and even though I'm still down a
pawn I think it's white who's playing
for a win
but I'm not sure how I can make
progress get the king
involved black has to kind of just
wait okay
wi win
this
Rook G4 Rook F7 then black can't stop
mate I'm pretty sure oh no I'm not even
threatening meat
though
um I think I still go for
it yeah the King has a G6
Square so
check
no stal
Matrix here I take it's not
stalemate
okay a slightly abrupt
ending oh good job to moner Haunter be
your first I am today in the tournament
very nice
job okay playing Super loop from planet
Earth
thank you dur G gifting to Chris
Doer
so yeah the plan is to get a knight to
F4 white wants to trap the
bishop which I think I'm okay with H5 I
can
take h
E4
what are my Knights
doing this is a
move okay opponent misses
it
oops not the best
conversion there we
go
okay not the most efficient way of
checkmating but I was trying to
orchestrate some G5
checkmates okay almost top 100 almost
one win
away
vely remember this game ah this is a
Catalan game I'll I'll berserk can
repeat the
[Music]
opening yeah I played this opponent
where they they blundered F2 pawn it was
slightly
different move Knight
D2
I had a very similar game in the first
stream of this
tournament where I did exactly this was
a same opening line trapping in the
Knight
A5 Knight is GNA be stuck
and has to sacrifice
itself okay so white has triple
eons
doesn't quite
work could play
F6 yeah there's not a great move for
white to defend the pawn maybe King
F2
okay so I'm up the
exchange oh no I'm up a full Rook okay I
was wondering like how why was I only up
the exchange but just
miscounted
think there's a mating idea
coming and give away the kingside
pawns oh it's not me
though
oops I was thinking Bishop
D1
okay still plenty of
time probably should not have allowed
the pawn to get that
far
okay I'm going to take a small
break uh
pause yeah almost top 100 first break of
the stream we'll watch a
game and I'll be
back
just put on this TV there we
go okay
BRB
okay got some coconut
water thank you code love G
[Music]
fuel here we
go
back to
tournament yeah I think top 50 is uh the
realistic goal almost top
100 berserk will'll play
E4 ooh we'll have one game with
pentatonic try and uh stay calm
here
H5 Queen side
Castle always play King
B1 savey
first that's a free
thing
and D5 incoming as
[Music]
well
Queen B2 takes should be
[Music]
fine
oops
okay back to standard sound
so top 100 96
place I see the comment from Jay Verna
learn so much from the YouTube YouTube
speedrun videos that's nice to hear yeah
more episodes coming
[Music]
soon
okay already some weird opening
here
an e five let just castle and then
E5
wow I'll get back the
piece
Oh I thought I was forking but I'm
not
oops oh that's not
good
okay this is
good wait what what did I
do
I don't know what I just did
there uh I don't know what I did
there like spaced out for a moment allow
the Ponda
Queen okay so I'm up
upon try and convert the advantage this
time yeah sometimes when I get like
these completely winning positions I get
too
relaxed but then sometimes my oppon just
resign and make life
easy okay so 90 fourth
place playing
[Music]
Rod
okay so there's less than three hours
left yeah this is a fun line the
prospect of uh G4 is quite
nice
Queen G3 I
fork here I'm just going for the
[Music]
kill I mind if Knight takes
um this is probably the most efficient
mate rather than taking the
[Music]
queen okay no more spite
checks that's M next
move
okay
92 playing Sergi ivanchuk
okay ston
wall
here's my stone
wall there one of these cases of good
Bishop versus not so good
Bishop C4 is hard to
stop hey it's Benjamin Bach appreciate
the
raid if you're just joining it's been a
long long
stream and it's going to go on longer
too also opponent wants to play this
move
I think I have to play
this tra in my own
Bishop I hope you have a good stream
Benjamin
Bach yeah this is a 24-hour Marathon
tournament on the chest winter
Marathon I played the first eight hours
then I slept I'm playing like the final
however
many did this
move wa I got to move
[Music]
faster
in some trouble here I think you should
do every one of these 24-hour
tournaments they are fun to watch quack
quack
here still me trap
incoming oh no it's
not I okay not meant to be what to
do there goes my
streak I'll try and
rebound this opponent I beat with
berserking
before forget the opening
kokan play this
line oh no my queen
Knight D5 is a good
move to play
this also thank you Sharma I appreciate
the
words and the
bits take
thank you nuttles beer gifting
five I'm in trouble
[Music]
here
um like what to do even like here or am
I in trouble iing
this I'm still looting a piece
though
got a couple pawns for
it some sneaky Discovery and we'll see
Queen
takes calculation is takes takes takes
here here
takes two pawns for a knight wait what
opponent didn't take my
queen
yeah this is a move that can only be
described as sleep
[Music]
deprivation I'm sure I've done similar
things this
tournament hopefully I can convert this
now
yeaw M queen and a few Pawns
King safety
first
okay I have played many marathons in the
past can probably do a search on my
YouTube
channel there's
been maybe close to a dozen that I've
played in
before
okay this
line this line has a draw tendency
but and no increment Blitz can still be
tricky
I might be winning the pawn
now oh no my
Bishop oh actually oh no my
Bishop this
move Rook C1 Bishop F1 there's no Bishop
D3 because I
mate
there's
that to play like I can't do that I have
to do
[Music]
this I think I'm losing the
bishop
wow oh my
thing I misplayed that that what should
I
do I thought I was being clever am I
just losing after Bishop
E4 Bishop E4 Bishop E5 oh it's still a
draw oh I had Rook A4
ah F4 oh F4 Rook F3
[Music]
too okay let a wake up
call I think I just stopped searching
and gave up
there okay playing
billik or
basilic we'll have a we play the
sign
um
yeah Bishops will be
traded
wow no
fear if I
take so ni's
hanging calculation is takes and I take
on
F3 so I'm up a
pawn
not for
long I have a tactic takes and then
take Queen
H4 just realized my key light wasn't
on it helps with lighting but also helps
me keep or keep uh keep myself awake
too okay let's
take might as well trade
Queens
H there's
G3 G3 okay so I'm going to have how many
pawns for the
Knight actually no G3
F5 yeah this should all be fine now
saving the
bishop
[Music]
thank you ARG olic
archeologic appreciate the 6
months and on just happy five
months
okay pretty routine
now
okay
91st welcome back to you
Jimmy remember you were here
earlier playing ACD
LS
okay let's play a nozle was
gabit haven't played one of these in a
[Music]
while Bishop
B5 okay so I went back the pawn I
basically went straight from the opening
to the end
game
this is kind of in between a middle game
and end game Queens are off the
board if we trade all the minor pieces I
think it's a winning King Pawn
ending although I don't want to fix box
pawns unless I'm winning no I'm not
winning a
pawn
knife F5 is
idea
that resembles a structure that you
sometimes see in the um Roy Lopez
exchange
variation yeah it's going to be hard to
win
though probably go for B 3
[Music]
C4
take doesn't really make a
difference
how probably a
draw there is one idea
to get the King close
[Music]
enough like this
move and then Knight
H4 that will tie down the king and then
maybe I
try and trade off the H
Pawn I think there's still life
here
I'm taking some risk going for this
oh the L gets
trapped
[Music]
okay now this should be
winning
oh there's Bishop
d8
okay I miss a fork what move number
I mean I think the King was on the light
Square for the most
time
here oh I missed a fork oops I should
have found that a
five what to
do I managed to win the hard
way
okay
berserk Stafford gab
time
I had this
recently it supposed to be check I had
this exact position recently after King
E2 Bishop G4 is a key
move and
then and then
what
um there's some nice line check and then
this
okay Stafford Gambit
success not so often you see this check
made from a
stord playing Super loop
again
I think this is
okay now I win the
bishop D4 could
be somewhat
troublesome
take the
Knight okay everything's covered now B2
is
[Music]
defended
um
got to move
faster
o play
this
the you
Sharma let's
trade Oh
[Music]
no just blundered
everything this is just force mate what
to
do okay
play one bad move I guess I'm I have to
take here game could keep
going oh good luck with your
knee yeah thanks for all the bits thanks
for being
here okay top 90 playing chess
Theory we've never played
before recognize that
flag oh that's a flare not a
flag
okay oh no that's a flag
huh all right let's
focus giving timeouts to a high rated
player
usually the Queen's on
C2 on
[Music]
D2 hopefully this thing still works it's
a Costa corly variation take and take
it's a super super sharp line I think it
works E5 I can take with
Rook yeah that's a very nice
[Music]
idea diagonal is
lethal
so I
have I have a lot of extra pawns here
Bishop
H3 maybe take
First bishop
H3 Queen of3 take and
[Music]
skewer
okay that was nice nice bit of opening
prep so over 400 tournament
points French been playing a lot of
different things against the
French playing this one
again
oops maybe it's not so
bad
okay we'll trade
everything not sure how I feel about
this not trading Rooks
though trying to play for a win with
some kingside
play
idea Rook
H3 I'm trying to use my space
Advantage the full
potential and this
first
yeah good move
take yeah I think it's just a
draw I
tried
oh
no still a
draw no it's
not I just
[Music]
do
I don't know what I just did
there oh what should I
do I was just losing after
that I guess I should just play King
C3 ah what to
do
okay top 100 is pretty amazing do you
have a goal for the
marathon thank you
Lumi uh the goal is top
50 the only prizes are virtual
trophies so I've I think there's a a
virtual trophy for top
50 yeah there's no money
prizes how many games have I played so
far also Stafford Gambit time KN
[Music]
G4 goals to win back
upon
so G3 I could take immediately
but this is slightly more accurate and
then
take okay so I have two Rooks for a
queen I've had this position probably a
handful of times
before white does need to be careful
here
uh maybe
B5 ambitious
move and pawns are
defended
if I can get the road to H file then
it's like very very close to winning but
it's hard to
achieve let start with
this okay now I do have a clear
plan that Rook defends this
Rook not simple
[Music]
idea Bishop D1 and Rook takes
C2
I want to try and play for a win
here
looking
good
okay that's a fun
game what's the strategy to win with two
Rooks ideally to
checkmat but the underlying strategy is
to like coordinate the Rooks like form
batteries Target pawns or Target the
OPP's
King
okay playing another Stafford the second
Stafford gamut in a
row we
have another game with
D3
I had this exact line a few games ago
ended in check made in 18
[Music]
moves this one might end
sooner okay ends in eight
moves that was
[Music]
fun almost 25,000 players in this
tournament it's an arena tournament so
people are free to join or leave
whenever or pause
[Music]
whenever okay let's play
this this is a fun
line Four Queens on the board by move
seven not too many openings feature this
line or feature this
occurrence
so one idea is to
take and then make another
queen
uh those pawns attacked a
bunch
Bishop Bishop
here uh blocks no fun okay now there's
only only one Queen for each of
us it's kind of
scary my king is really lacking Shel
got to move quicker
too some counter play with Rook
here
yeah this is winning
that was a fun
game Oops I meant to
check
okay
okay I've
played 177 games so far win rate 68%
could be
nicer berserk rat almost half or over
half of the
games playing card a
nine another attempted
Stafford not
happening
if G4 I might be able to
take what to do
here preparing to maybe Castle Queen
side
that's a sharp game
now I want to play
G4 white wants to open the a
[Music]
file Bishop can't take as I take
G4 I probably take with
Knight have takes I take Rook A8 Knight
B8 these positions is are usually like
all about
initiative usually comes down to who can
generate the biggest threats
like gives a
queen I looks scary but I think things
are under
[Music]
control you take this
way
okay yeah that got very
sharp oh playing mysterious experts who
is leading the tournament
earlier and then I think maybe got some
sleep play
E4 let's play something
[Music]
solid trying to
remember
any any ideas here it's like a
Belgrade me take
more like mysterious International
master
yeah some tension between the
Queens go for
G4
a lot of Trades
there should be roughly equal there's
Queen G5 Rook
[Music]
D2 that's a good
move okay I'm trying to hunker
[Music]
down
some D5
idea
[Music]
um
I'm probably in trouble
here
really risky
[Music]
move
okay now now it's
winning or is
it it's not
winning still super
tricky
okay oh took a lot of work
yeah the move I initially wanted to play
is Queen C2 the problem is uh Queen E5
check and then Rook
B1
so I'm I should be losing
here I was expecting Queen
B1 I didn't see the clear win Queen A1
Rook
[Music]
A2
it still takes some work for black
probably eventually
taking okay Escape that one top
80 421
points rating is still on the
rise playing OG
Vladik and two knights
attack
pretty sure this is
winning okay now it's definitely
winning
okay you Mr immortality gifting to dark
rug so I had a long fight and a very
quick game there
uh let's play a
sicilian
[Music]
wow not easy to
punish
oops and Sh it's probably okay defend I
pin E6 can't be taken or
can but now we trade
Queens oops forgot that was
attacked
okay well that was just equal
[Music]
material
um down a little bit of
time
that that's not
good
what to
do okay stay mentally
strong playing this
person Stafford Gambit time no kin
Gambit
[Music]
time a slightly dubious G habit but I'll
try and make it
work marry almost 2020 for
Eric yeah New Year is quickly
approaching welcome back to Sock fish
really want to play
E5 still takes work to
achieve
[Music]
h
okay
uh what to
do okay no
berserking less than two hours
left
a risky Pawn to
take I
[Music]
mean I think I'm holding on
though some F5
[Music]
idea I guess black wants to take
here actually that one material I'm down
to change
now
okay try and
survive it's incredible the rook and the
B Bishop are completely
stuck so I'm not sure what black is
supposed to
do oh The King The Rook is getting out
though
F5
it's interesting
position black is almost in
zugang like almost okay now I can
take
okay this should be winning okay that
was a cool finish like black got
completely paralyzed
there 77 playing Sam
[Music]
musan
okay I can see that the bishop
here
but have decent
pieces this could be another endgame
grind so attacking the bishop and the
[Music]
pawn oh Pablo started the tournament an
hour ago made it to top
5200 yeah it gets
competitive a lot of players uh play for
many many
hours not sure how many players play the
whole
thing it got to be less than like 5% or
less than
2%
I just missed this
move but I just found this
move I might be allergic to winning
pawns um let's not lose any pawns
though cure a bishop here
thank you for all the
blessings
okay I'm up for
pawns it's a large
quantity
oh no my
[Music]
Pawn okay now I'm at Five
Pawns
okay it's going to be hard to get into
top
50 still a lot of points to make
up no
[Music]
berserking okay all
berserk
the block has three pawns for
the
bishop
yeah winning The Rook
helps
okay gain three rating points for
that thank you shinger happy 46
months
I think one plan is to play F3
G4 and
attack okay some
tatic
Knight G3 I have Queen E5
now night
G3 I don't have Queen
E5 okay I'm still up a
pawn should be
okay
wow take
[Music]
take
okay hold on to the draw there's one pre
move I made there that would have been
pretty bad but uh okay I'll take
it sta for gabit
[Music]
time
wow
B5
so the goal is to bring the Knight to
C4 prevent Rook here
Bish B5 is a good
[Music]
move can I
take what is this King Pawn
[Music]
ending
I think I think it's
winning yeah King
B3 okay that was a a satisfying
finish oh 30 points away from top 50
okay playing
[Music]
Farmville
yeah not the best
position
maybe uh
8 and then
push
there Bishop
F5 like almost
works but I take with
Chuck
oo
for
here in takes I have Rook
G8 there's Bishop D3 in that
[Music]
line
oops that's not
good his opponent did State me in the
past but
probably not going to happen there yeah
good game interesting
fight probably a slightly worse in the
middle game
there
okay 73rd
Place try and stay
focus Rook
E8
if takes I'm
meeting meanwhile actually Knight F1 H5
is
interesting wait I could have just taken
the
Knight I probably should have just taken
the Knight it should still be winning
because yeah
this
take and then
check and then
here o E6
checkmates I actually didn't see that
coming only realized it was made until
after I made the
move okay playing cranberry
cheese
uh what do I want to play
C5
yeah that was a free
pawn bishop c7's
idea
oh am I losing something I might
be actually no I still am
take
95 try
this and this not a happy move to
play Oh B4 is coming
[Music]
too I'm going to be down to full
Rook
yeah it was a good
opening
I should have just played
[Music]
B4 some ounce of
Hope
that's
a very high quality Pawn on
B3 idea this this unleash the
bishop lots of Hope
[Music]
now
I win this
Pawn
not sure how this
happened I was down a full Rook
earlier okay I cheesed the cranberry
cheese
okay I've been studying more chess but
losing more now is that
normal uh that is actually sometimes
when you study chess you're absorbing a
lot of new
Concepts and it causes you to like think
differently go outside your comfort
zone um that was a quick
game uh it's kind of the nature of
growing
pains this is maybe most frequent when
you're learning new openings
or switching like an opening
repertoire even learning a different
style of
play but in the long run should trust
just try and Trust the
process it took me a while to make this
realization because it can be very
frustrating when you you study hard and
then lose a lot of games
but um if you focus on just overall
knowledge and
Improvement then eventually the results
will
[Music]
come okay these pieces are all kind
of smooshed up on the queen
side want go for
some attacking
ideas like very close to
mates I mean G6 is the best try but I'll
win The
Rook Hey top 60 65 five making
progress wow what is
this what is this
opening I played some weird Gambit but
now it's white trying to
Gambit an H file to work
with
I could sack back maybe just this
first what is
[Music]
happening
check Rook agent one is kind of
funny but then King F2
trying to build the
battery okay that was a fun game F4 G5
what do we call
this I saw Magnus play this against
Raven St in title Tuesday the Hobs
Gambit
okay 62nd
Place playing
E4
ooh uh L wi Gambit let's
go have to remember what to do
here let's
go
I basically played the wing gamut
against the
bird I I had more powerful
wings uh what to do with my
queen Queen's almost
trapped
have to play like
[Music]
G4 I don't think that helps
though
yeah this
backfired now I'm getting crushed by the
laian
CIT oh no my
queen
threatening
this wow that may have been a mouse flip
but that's what I need some bated
Christmas miracle New Year's
Miracle CU I'm going to win this and
then probably this
I'm still down a lot of time
[Music]
though two Rooks and a bishop for the
piece or for the
queen
no man what am I
doing
okay what is black
doing 8
Seconds
a too slow too
slow H frustrating but what to do almost
a miracle comeback
next game playing this
person 1 hour and 5 minutes
left berserking a high rated
opponent this is a fun
line usually D4 I can
take I still take
here
okay hopefully I can win this
position plenty of
time yeah okay 13 move win let's
go
I played shuvalov a few times before we
usually get like cambri Springs or
something
similar maybe exchange
variation play this
one oh yeah Queen
C2
I'm trying to be solid
here yeah some trade of Pawns and
probably
Bishops
I'm going
for positional
play
trying to be patient
here not really the move I wanted to
play
is this position really changed with the
kingside
structure I just blunder the
pawn yeah it's not
good
trying to stay
alive a that was a bad
move not
good
oh
okay
resign uh what to do 64th Place 1 hour
left okay
berserk play
ponziani
Knight C2 is playable
there
good game well played was good
fights
okay
65th have a good score against this
opponent oh is this the game from
earlier that
um Queen
D2 White's doing something a little bit
different we might have the same no we
have a different line here I
can
take should take F4
there almost
Works let's try it F4 is coming okay
well was not expecting the free Queen
I'll take
it okay
almost top
60 shout out to Kings
rusher not berserking
back
trying to win a
pawn
threading a
fork KN
C3
thank you Fool's
mate I had this
move still
do
I'm just
simplifying okay got the job done top
60 final push 53 minutes
left scandy time
that's a good opening no
draw
it's a cool
idea not a tastic you see too
often take there
just move
back
okay that that turned into something
that wasn't really chess but okay got
this job done there I'm usually pretty
slow in those situations
but had to unleash the
Speed playing chess
Theory I did beat
earlier in some
game
have a solid position
here thank you moo happy eight
months I'll maneuver the Knight to
D3 box doing similar
[Music]
things yeah what should do oh E5 might
be coming
with E5 I can take in Bishop
G5 it's scary
though big
Center another a
four four is kind of a cool
move kind of questioning how black will
defend the pawn might see Queen
F7 take
first doesn't do
much
[Music]
I didn't really achieve
anything Queen
D1 so the point is if takes I take take
and then
take oh but the knight's defended
oops so I'm basically bluffing here oh
maybe I can
take here first and then
here
there's this
pin and then the bishop won't be
defended like after takes
takes if Queen E6 I win the Knight
otherwise I win the
bishop some weird T tactical uh
sequence and Black's whole Center is now
basically
dissolved
like if black doesn't take the
bishop yeah life is pretty good now
although is my Bishop
trapped my Bishop's
trapped okay counterattacking with the
battery very interesting
game some weird
tactics rookie one is a
threat thank you Alexander's
horse thanks everyone for tuning in
too I appreciate everyone who's
here and my bishop's still trapped
though
um but can black take it because if
takes I take with
Knight there's still
initiative there's a funny line takes
takes King h8 and I take on D6
go for
this allowing
knight8 still pressure I've broken two
pawns for Knight and
Bishop Bishop's
[Music]
pinned Queen E1 is a
threat and be
safe yeah what to do
here
recovers
H2
oops
[Music]
good
game
oh tough one tough
one
58th and having some of these crazy time
scrambles playing Jay Coco again let's
play this uh gamut again it worked well
previously h six I
think and attack the
pawn threatening the fork
I am playing a little bit recklessly
here maybe it'll pay off
can take
[Music]
B7 trying to keep the E file
closed
such a strong
move
okay a little bit faster that
game oh
man
okay played this opponent once
earlier
Knight
D4 meant to play Queen H2 but not the
worst Mouse slip
ever play this
first 39 minutes
left trying to build up some attack
here
m yeah we're just
trading okay I'm go for
this
[Music]
C7
here I probably have the
fork also combined with a
pin
[Music]
allowing Rook
C6
okay happy to
simplify
it's time to use the
king tricky
[Music]
move
and why allowed
that
okay
oh opponent was a little bit slow there
wow let's keep it going um playing chest
Theory
again don't berserk back that's
okay still
Theory
looks like a nice
[Music]
position actually white can't stop the
triple fork or the the fork of some sort
yeah okay
okay a nice quick win 52nd Place getting
closer I think I'm at a peak rating for
this
stream okay no
berserking try and keep my
streak
we're going to have the same opening not
quite Bishop
F4 Bishop F4 I can challenge the bishop
right
away
So the plan is to kind of get this setup
on the king
side and potentially go for some
attack it is kind of hard to orchestrate
an attack
though I'm trying to be
patient
I think white wanted to prepare okay
prepare E4 I
guess can
take yeah D5 is hard to stop
Queen
F4 Queen B3 is coming I have to play
this that's not not under a
queen I'm not that
exhausted white slightly better
here
95 E5
F4 Rook
C8 so now I'm threatening to take use
the C5
Knight D6 is almost playable have to
take with a rook
I know I I couldn't resist it was like
too much Temptation I don't think it
works there's a line Queen E2 KN
F6 but this line ah this
yeah okay I can't take the
Knight I'm trying to make something out
of
this KN C3
[Music]
coming
a little bit surprised Uris about that
[Music]
decision two Rooks for Queen and two
pawns that was losing but I'll try and
fight
okay I don't know how I won that but
I'll take
it some point it was two Rooks against
Queen and
Knight
that's a strong
[Music]
move probably should have played King B1
take
wow
play have to take oh no my
oh yes my
[Music]
2024 I'm suffering here but block
doesn't take on E2
[Music]
wow opponent showed some
mercy that's still not great
maybe some
chances
hey got close there got close 52nd
Place could be a close
finish had a streak
too playing
Biff
just losing a
[Music]
PA can't really defend
that
G5
hope this toing back a PA
[Music]
somehow
ready to take
doops or just blunder my
knight oh I forgot how the Night
[Music]
Moves
please play Knight C8 what's the
equivalent of thanking the bus driver in
chess uh thank you for the free
Knight it's still not great for black
though unfortunately maybe
it's there there
there yeah it's still
[Music]
losing unless I can play
this
I hope you're having proper coffee today
instead of that iced nonsense
um the IC nonsense has melted and it's
almost
gone also look at this
nonsense chat
oh what
nonsense wait is a draw though Perpetual
where's my
peret I think it's
peret no it's not perpet or is it no
it's
not
opponent doesn't see it
though I mean I can't really avoid
it check May me check
here
drop I usually don't offer draws but
it's one of those
cases
no it's not a
draw
check what to
do threatening madeen one it's a funny
madeen one
threat stop
it stop it stop it stop
it okay not meant to be almost making a
queen epic
comeback no
okay uh 55th wow it's going to be really
close I need I need like 10 more points
I think
this person's
paused okay
berserk we saw this opening
earlier I'll play something a bit more
aggressive
[Music]
there we
go
no
mercy okay
need to rock up the winds quickly
491 I'll need to hit
500 berserk
again Cambridge Springs
time Bishop
H4 I think I've seen this move
before
okay
be ambitious
here wait a
minute I forgot the night was hanging
I could have taken
first okay Queens are
traded
okay should be winning the
Knight Rook C7 King
D6
thank you aod the first time
Prime
good
try
Okay 55
yeah the next couple games are crucial I
probably only have time for like two or
three more
games trying to finish strong carocon
God okay we'll play a
carolan
full Rook now black has a pawn Cube
but not even God can sa that position
with the pawn Cube
okay 50 First Place
499 home
stretch playing
sahaya no berserking okay
berserking
[Music]
now the gr
transformation this idea or this
idea
oops
I'm really misplaying
this
really
D okay oh it's going to be really close
work I have to play Super aggressively
here opponent burning
time or o
time yeah this is an opening to play to
try and win as quickly as
[Music]
possible it's kind of
working very
clever still a fight
upon
so H7 is a target I think it's
winning it looks drawn but this should
be
[Music]
winning black king should have probably
G6
there almost
Zang
okay 50
seconds time for one more
game next game will probably be the last
game
505 so still Within
Reach nice double berserk King's
gandit can take
this
not looking
[Music]
good
can't believe I allowed that
tournament's
over take there to play
this
okay I resign what to do the
tournament's over I finished in 50
something 502nd place got
close rating
2552 all the 52s 52 Place 2552 with 502
tournament
points okay okay thank you everyone for
watching that was a lot of
Chess I played 22
games oh yeah and this is the 52nd week
of the year
right it's an
[Music]
OM a new year to
come anyway I'm kind of
tired thank you JJ the ultra bullet
lover some of these time scrambles felt
like Ultra bullet that's some crazy ones
towards the
end I think I lost a little bit of
rating
but not that bad
considering had a lot of uh rough
patches some nice streaks had that one
long streak
earlier so um if you're watching in the
future on
YouTube congratulations on making it
through the end of the video let me know
what your favorite game was out of the
22 games I played stay tuned for more
content